hey everyone warned here with some
awesome news about the Fantastic Four
Deadpool the x-men and all of the other
Fox characters that Disney is about to
get there have been some recent
developments and updates and Kevin Feige
himself the president of Marvel Studios
has even commented on when to expect
some of these characters in the MCU real
quick there is only a handful of days
left for my Infinity Gauntlet giveaway I
will be choosing the winner on January
1st so if you would like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel with the
notifications turned on like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
as of right now it's looking like the
Disney Fox deal will be done in January
now of course that could change but as
of right now that's when it's looking
like it's going to be done and finalized
that means that Marvel and Disney will
finally own the rights to characters
such as the Fantastic Four the x-men the
Silver Surfer Galactus and other awesome
characters as well so they can finally
put them in the MCU and connect them
with all of the heroes that we currently
know and love
so it looks like the deal is going to be
done in January which means that Disney
and Marvel can start using these
characters in the MCU
in an interview with Variety Kevin Feige
the president of Marvel Studios was
asked when we could start seeing these
characters in the MCU and when we will
start to see movies developed for these
characters and here's what he had to say
we've been told it's looking very very
good and could happen in the first six
months of next year the notion of the
characters coming back is great it's
nice when a company that created all
these characters can have access to all
these characters it's unusual not to but
in terms of actually thinking about it
and actually planning things we haven't
started that yet so this is great news
according to Kevin Feige if everything
goes according to plan movies and
stories could start being developed for
Deadpool the x-men and the Fantastic
Four in the first half of 2019 Kevin
Feige has actually said that he would
like to introduce the Fantastic Four
into the MCU first so that is most
likely to be the first movie to start
development keep in mind that this is
just development it does not mean that
we will get one of these movies in 2019
they
to start the development for them if
everything goes according to plan so
they will start development on these
movies for them to come out in maybe
late 2020 or 2022 pretty soon and won't
seem like too far away considering that
we have a really packed movie schedule
for Marvel movies in 2019 so the
Fantastic Four the x-men Deadpool
Galactus the Silver Surfer and all these
other characters are not too far away
from entering the MCU let me know how
excited you are for this news and let me
know which character you're most excited
to see enter the MCU let me know in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe with the
notifications turned on like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
you can enter the Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway and so you can stay up to date
on everything we relating to the Disney
Fox deal and so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers
endgame as always thank you all so much
for watching Wolf Wolf
you
[Music]